[Music]
paul is in cincinnati hey paul welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave hope you're doing better than
you deserve i am sir how can we help
hey so uh i've been listening for just
uh one week uh my wife and i are
actually on baby step two right now um
we've got about 250 000 in debt about
130 of that is our mortgage we just
bought a house in april
the other
120
is
between car and student loans between my
wife and i
just didn't know what the heck we were
doing when we went into school
especially me 80 of that is from my
student loans
been working in children's services for
the past seven years recently got a job
as a non-profit manager with a free
clothing boutique for foster kids
thankfully making a little bit more
money i've got about three or four more
years to go for the public service loan
forgiveness program and i'm wondering
is it
better to
try to get
actual forgiveness from that program or
start paying down those loans now
considering i've got
you know less than five years to go for
it
well here's the problem with the pslf
okay
um last year
or since it began rather in the last
couple of years it's really started
kicking in
726
000 people have applied for it after
working 10 years
in a non-profit or a qualified area
right which is what you're trying to do
right 726 000 people have applied for it
all of them but 8 400 were turned down
so far
so far the program has a
1.16 percent
approval rating
approval rate i guess is a better way of
saying it so what that says is 99 of the
people
who were on what you're trying to do it
didn't work
um i don't know how to say that anyway
except say that the government lied
because they
you know they are finding some reason
to not execute the student loan
forgiveness there's three types of
student loan forgiveness death
if you die your student loan is forgiven
if you your spouse or whoever's left
behind sends in a death certificate
they'll forgive your student loan
it doesn't pass right it doesn't pass on
to your estate it doesn't count against
your estate
disability if you become permanently
disabled and sign up for and qualify for
ssi under the social security department
then you can take that qualification and
have your student loans forgiven
and then there is a few actually there's
four types there's another type that is
underserved areas
and most of those forgiveness programs
are three years not 10. the biggest one
that everybody's plugged into is this
10-year program that you're in the
public student loan forgiveness program
and so far the other three actually do
work they actually do forgive you it's a
lot of hassle to go through it but
so far the folks on your plan are at a
99 failure rate
and so if i saw that and i was in your
shoes i wouldn't be counting on the
government to help me yeah that's the
biggest problem is it's just not
reliable the idea behind it is great i
see why a lot of people feel you know
that they want to follow that plan it's
just like you said the numbers the data
of who've actually had their payments
forgiven that's just not showing up
nobody yeah so it's just not something
you can count in and especially since
we've seen so many people pay off their
debt by getting on a budget following
the baby steps we know you can do it
without waiting and that's a proven
reliable plan so i my vote is that you
take control of what you can control and
to start paying down the debt versus
waiting to see if the government might
forgive it and here here's an
interesting thing almost philosophically
that goes with that that we do find in
the data of people who become like baby
steps millionaires you're right your
vote is is correct
the people who build wealth
control
what they know they can control
and that's the person in your mirror
in other words they depend upon
themselves
not an outside force to cause their
prosperity
and psychologists call that the locus of
control where is it you look
what source do you look to
to
cause you to do this and even those of
us that are people of faith we look to
god
but the you know but when you're a
christian
god says
uh those that don't work don't let them
eat god says uh you reap what you sow so
if you want some corn you should plant
some corn
god says you know you know the these
if you sow sparingly if you put out very
little work or very little corn you're
going to get very little corn back and
these are very these are principles of
life that we see
uh you know agricultural uh analogies
but their principles of life and so this
locus of control this idea that my
destiny
is most likely going to come to pass
when i cause it to um don't have control
over all the variables i can't control
idiots i can't control racists i can't
control people that hate people from the
south i can't control people and hate
people on talk radio i can't control all
of that but i can control what i do
and when you have that you're exactly
right christina there's a high
correlation between that type of person
or the person that adopts that mentality
and the person that succeeds
financially so all of that to say
go pay off your student loans right well
and in contrast to that with the public
student loan forgiveness program even if
it did in theory work the way that they
said that paper that payments were
processed correctly there still are
things within that that you can't
control you could get laid off you could
change jobs you could move locations
we've heard some horror stories of
people who you know they did what they
were supposed to do for years and then
at the last minute right something
changed that they had no control over
and it disqualified them you know what
there's another type of loan forgiveness
that does work 100 too and no joe i'm
not joking it is the
if the institution like if you went to
one of these rip-off colleges and they
go broke
then they loan that that you took out to
go to the college that went broke is
forgiven and that's what's going around
right now uh joe biden just forgave five
billion dollars no it was current
corinthian college and uh it went broke
and it was a huge
huge scam
huge
and uh a lot of people went and so the
this latest wave of loans that biden
forgave he didn't forgive him it was
department of education by regulation
forgave it had nothing to do with the
white house it had nothing to do with
politics it had to do with that that was
already on the books if the college that
you go to goes bankrupt and you took out
student loans that student loan can be
forgiven automatically it's a regulation
it's not a white house dictate and it's
not a i get to say i forgave student
loans you didn't have nothing to do with
it